[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je me suis souvent entendu dire
ces derniers temps mais toi j'ai forte
c'est normal j'ai la ressource mais toi
c'est parce que c'est toi qui a réussi
ou alors encore le summum c'est cette
façon on n'est pas inquiet pour toi
alors non ça n'a pas été plus facile
pour moi non ce n'est pas si semble
alors ce soir j'ai choisi de vous
raconter une histoire c'est l'histoire
d'une petite fille qui arrive au monde
dans un foyer heureux avec des parents
épanouis et amour est un grand frère et
mais elle vit dans un village
authentique niché dans les eaux d'un
petit village de saint denis
hélas une enfance heureuse elle vit
entourée de ses cousins et de ses
cousines digne de la petite maison dans
la prairie
tout se passe bien et puis du haut de
ses 9 ans littéralement le ciel va lui
tomber sur la tête du jour au lendemain
elle se couche la veille dans ce foyer
heureux et elle se lève le lendemain et
tout explose ses parents se déchirent
ea n'a rien vu venir le mot est lâché
ils se séparent ils divorcent qu'est ce
qu'elle trouve ce mot-là moche didot
divorce et c'est se séparer de se
détourner d'eux est littéralement c'est
contre nature vous allez vous allez me
dis quand son père va se détourner
d'elle le reverra son père et son frère
qu'à l'âge de 17 ans donc du jour au
lendemain sa vie bascule elle doit
quitter ses amis son école en urgence
changer de ville découvrir une nouvelle
vie de ceux du haut de ses 9 ans
apprendre la vie en solo avec sam
mais de l'extérieur quand on regarde
cette petite fille on se dirait mais
tout va bien en fait elle est juste en
train apprend à mettre un couvert sur
ses émotions
et puis toujours dans cette nouvelle vie
d'enfant qui normalement cet âge là ça
doit ça doit durer le plus longtemps
possible pour qu'on puisse se préparer à
la vie adulte elle en train sans le
savoir de se forger les croyances fortes
qui vont la rattraper à l'âge adulte
la peur de l'abandon la peur de
l'incertitude donc développé la notion
de contrôle une relation très complexe
avec les hommes mais de l'extérieur on a
toujours l'air elle a toujours l'air
d'être bien est elle en train
d'apprendre qu'elle sera la reine de la
sueur adaptation plus tard mais au fond
la seule protection qu'elle va trouver à
ce moment là c'est de se réfugier dans
la nourriture et son corollaire
l'obésité qui l'accompagné dès son plus
jeune âge elle va des cc devant
apprendre à vivre la différence avec une
société où peut-être leur diktat du
paraître
ou peut être en fait la femme doit avoir
un corps parfait mais tant bien que mal
elle continue dans la vie elle traverse
l'adolescence l'âge adulte elle trouve
un job elle se marie jusqu'ici tout va
bien vous allez me dire mais au final
elle traîne quand même toujours avec
elle une grosse valise vous savez où
alain thériault ya des grosses pierres
c'est un peu comme des déboulés attachés
aux chevilles
vous voulez avancer mais ça vous retient
quelque chose qui va pas mais j'essaie
d'avancer en fait dans cette valise
il y avait des blessures et des
croyances forte
la première qui étaient très profondes
c'était qu'elle pensait vraiment qu'elle
avait moins de valeur que les autres
parce qu'elle ne faisait pas une taille
elle pense également qu'elle n'était pas
assez intelligente qu'elle n'avait pas
de ressources
elle n'était pas forte vous l'aurez
compris elle n'était pas bien dans ses
baskets et dans bien que mal
elle continue toujours vous allez me
dire mais en fait je peuvent le tedx
pour ça c'est triste elle fait sa
victime ou quoi non non attendez la
suite et donc elle continue sa vie et la
première métamorphose la première
guérison ça va être un long combat pour
perdre 50 kg elle change elle découvre
l'élégance la féminité une première
lumière en fait arrivé dans sa vie mais
n'a pas encore le recul nécessaire pour
savoir ce qui va arriver une porte se
retrouve comme elle était dessus elle
s'acharne encore un peu parce que
finalement elle est allé soigner
l'extérieur avant d'aller soigner
l'intérieur mais voilà le jour de ses 30
ans se passe quelque chose je commence à
avoir pas mal de questions qui passe
dans sa tête son corps lui donne des
alertes forte mais en fait elle n'a pas
envie d'aller voir ce qu'il se dit
qu'est ce que je vais découvrir
et puis peut-être que ce que je vais
découvrir je vais devoir prendre des
décisions
je n'ai pas envie je vais rester dans le
déni mais très vite ça va la rattraper
son corps va lui donner encore des
alertes encore plus forte une angoisse
qui valent à paralyser au point de ne
plus pouvoir aller travailler de devoir
fuir la foule et qui adore tellement
contact et une perte de poids trop
importante
vous allez me dire c'est cool quand même
pour une ancienne obèse
hélène se dit non je peux pas rester
comme ça je vais aller voir
elles entament une démarche en fait de
développement personnel pour aller
derrière ses blessures et derrière son
enfant l'intérieur écrit arrive l'année
2013 je reviens sur ce talk de ce soir
vous devez encore vous dire mais c'est
plus négatif le tedx non quand vous
l'aurez compris cette histoire est l'ami
et si j'avais envie de vous la raconter
c'est parce qu'une fois que je suis allé
quérir cet enfant intérieur
une fois que j'aurai mis le curseur au
bon endroit il y aura que du bonheur et
donc je reviens sur cette année 2013
en fait je suis né en 1977 et en 2013
j'ai vécu ma deuxième naissance
pourtant cette année 2013 avait mal
commencé
je décide enfin de divorcer oui je dis
enfin nous concernant et je subis aussi
les conséquences et le jugement des
autres mais il faut dire aussi que je
m'étais bien débrouillé pendant des
années pour reconstruire une image de
femme parfaite avec un mari et des
aloses un mariage parfait
donc j'assume je perds mon job
après 15 ans a là rien et là j'ai des
questions comme le statut social passe
ici je suis à la recherche d'un emploi
adacore et puis je perds ma grand mère
ma grand mère pour moi c'était vraiment
l'image de la femme réunionnaise dans
toute sa splendeur avec une force de
caractère à toute épreuve et en fait à
ce moment là c'est difficile pour moi
évidemment pendant deux mois je déprime
je suis pas bien je ne m'occupe pas de
moi je n'ai plus envie de sortir je me
dis que c'est pas juste
pourquoi ça m'arrive à moi salir son
qu'est ce que je vais faire à
l'élastique du passé revient je me
réfugie de nouveau dans la nourriture
mais à un moment donné je me dis comme
cette année elle est la sienne
qu'est-ce que tu choisis tu subis
justement où tu choisis est-ce que c'est
pas ton moment de renaître justement
dans la vie et c'est le choix que je
vais faire au moment de cette année 2013
où je vais dans un premier temps
d'amuser je vous passe les détails
entre nous vous dansez sur les barres de
la côte ouest mais c'est entre nous
j'assume
j'en avais besoin alors je suis en train
de dire à toutes les femmes de la salle
qu'il faut divorcer pour danser sur les
barres non mais moi je me suis amusé
j'ai voyagé j'ai vraiment profité j'ai
eu un sourire je me suis éclairé et puis
je me suis dit sa femme ont permis de
reprendre ses études
mais comme tu avais cette croyance que
tu n'étais pas assez intelligent tu ne
l'a pas fait j'ai repris mes études et
je me suis développé je me suis formé
par don de développement humain j'avais
aussi envie d'entreprendre depuis très
longtemps mais pareil
cette force sous-estiment de moi même
empêché de le faire donc à ce moment là
je le fais j'ai découvert un métier je
découvre que accompagné lot c'est
quelque chose de formidable
mais avant de pouvoir accompagner
l'autre en fait j'avais besoin d'eux
mais des mois avant de pouvoir aider les
autres
moi en fait dans mon parcours que je
suis en train de vous raconter je ne
savais pas ce qui allait m'arriver
j'avais juste envie de sortir de la
souffrance et en fuyant cette souffrance
je me suis rendu compte que j'ai dis
sinon un tableau mais j' avais aucune
idée parce que de ce qu'allait être ce
tableau à la fin j'ai juste mis quelques
petites pierres des ratures j'ai enlevé
je sais pas et j'ai finalement réussi à
dessiner le tableau qui me ressemble et
c'est ça que je vous propose aujourd'hui
alors est-ce que j'ai peur toujours est
ce que j'ai des doutes toujours mais
c'est la façon d'aborder qui est
différent je suis en alignement avec moi
même pas ce que dit moi allons entre
nous qui n'a pas un jour eu envie de
faire différemment mais n'a pas osé
alors moi ce que j'ai envie de vous dire
ce soir c'est oser oser oser et voyez
grand parce qu'en écrivant sutton
j'utilisais au début le mot changer les
genoux sur mon compte que je n'avais pas
changé en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que j'ai juste accepter celle que
j'étais déjà et j'ai juste accepté de
laisser jaillir le potentiel et le
talent et moi je suis entièrement
convaincu que tous ici nous avons du
potentiel
nous avons du talent et je suis aussi
intimement convaincu à la une
on ya un potentiel extraordinaire est
généralement aussi cette sensation que
c'est un peu comme un artiste qui est de
la personne à se dessiner
d'où est venue koudou est venu
maintenant mon métier qui en fait
designers de talent et enfin juste pour
terminer je vais vous montrer une photo
et pour moi symbolise vraiment celle que
je suis aujourd'hui
elles m'ont authenticité ma fierté de
mes origines je suis fier d'être
réunionnaise avec une ouverture d'esprit
sur cette photo vous avez maintenant en
mer vous avez mon papa et ma maman et
moi même je trouve que j'étais que
j'étais déjà une belle fashion victim
s'enlacent à moi avec ma petite robe à
carreaux et en fait ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est ce qu'on doit punir les
parents mais non ils n'ont pas une
manuelle
ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
aujourd'hui j'apprends à pardonner je
parle surtout de mon père qui j'apprends
pardonnez ma maman elle a été là pour
moi les là ce soir et je voulais juste
vous dire j'étais fière de toi maman si
je suis debout sur cette scène
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à toi
[Applaudissements]